so you're like 21 years old and twilight
becomes very successful and you've
described that you couldn't even go
anywhere it's kind of like being lady
die it is as close as you're going to
get so do you bring that into the role
of lady die do you say yeah i know what
this woman went through
yeah i definitely i definitely
understand the very clear parallel
between our lives having so many lenses
in them so many constant
looky-loos and uh i mean i guess the
difference is that when i make a movie i
really want everyone to go see it and so
right you know i'm not stoked to go get
coffee and bring my like trail of
[ __ ] cretans with me and it's
embarrassing and it's like kind of like
uh
i don't know it just is silly it kind of
it just sort of sucks the life out of
certain moments but at the same time i'm
like so leaning
in because i want everyone to see my
movie i also am allowed to say whatever
the [ __ ] i want i can make
stupid mistakes i can fall on my face
and nobody's gonna like kick me out of
the family i think with her she was just
she couldn't speak
all of her ways of communicating were so
weird and sideways diagonal kind of
cryptic like
she wore
you know an outfit to feel strong and
you could tell that night like jesus
christ you're a little overdressed it's
like well i'm [ __ ] pissed at my
husband and i want him to see this or
she's like i'm gonna put my head down
and stare at you with my eyes like a
crazy person like this like
undulating swan because i can't say my
husband is not in love with me and i'm
in pain and i i have
you know more to say than i'm allowed to
did you ever get one of those situations
where the paparazzi are chasing you and
someone starts driving fast and says
don't worry i'll get you out of here
yeah i've definitely experienced that
and and every time we drive through
the tunnel in paris which is like a main
thoroughfare it's
if you ever spend time like you will
probably go like
whatever i've i've
been in vehicles
going through that tunnel
being chased by really aggressive
paparazzi in paris they're really really
really aggressive on on scooters and
cars and bikes and
um before i
ever thought of doing this movie i
had those experiences being like man and
look where we are and everyone just
chill and we're not gonna you know go
crazy and make this more dangerous than
it needs to be but they'll do everything
it's yeah your advice is so smart it's
true okay it's bad situation they're
trying to take our picture it's
dangerous they're following us in a car
but [ __ ] it slow down and let them take
your picture you don't want to die
at doing this thing it's crazy how she
died it is crazy when i would remember
what happened which which occasion
occasionally happened i would be
re-shattered every single time i would
just start crying like
i just i still sitting here right now i
cannot believe that that's what went
down like that's how it all shook out i
can't understand it